last week in a series of angles I warned
Senate Republicans that if they don't
step up and vociferous ly defend this
president against this ongoing farce
guess what Democrats would exact revenge
on them if they heaven forbid went on to
win big in 2020 now as if on cue the
Washington Post reported over the
weekend that a quote growing number of
GOP senators consider acknowledging
Trump's quid pro quo on Ukraine and of
course the media they're running wild
with it some Republicans in the Senate
are on the brink of publicly admitting
that there was a Ukraine quid pro quo
and that directly contradicts what the
president has been saying some set of
Republicans are arguing for a shift in
strategy acknowledging the quid pro quo
but insisting it is not an impeachable
offense a republican party and it's
those close to the president realizing
that they have nowhere else to go other
than acknowledging that there was in
fact a quid pro quo
hold on there counselor joining me now
is Lindsey Graham chairman of the Senate
Judiciary Committee senator is this true
and is this just a rhetorical argument
okay just assuming all your facts Adam
and Nancy and company assuming all
everything you say so we deny it but
assuming it's still not a peaceful is
that what's going on I think maybe a
little bit that here's what you can take
from this whole discussion there's not
one vote for impeachment removal from
office based on the phone call in the US
Senate
I don't believe Mitt Romney would vote
to remove the president over the phone
call because one he did nothing wrong if
that's the impeachable offense you won't
have any presidents left I'm not in
Kentucky tonight a lot of kids behind
them had read the transcript t-shirts I
really want of course I read the
transcript gosh you don't respect me of
course I read it many times just to get
you going there's nothing wrong that
phone call did he say unless you
investigate my opponent Joe Biden I will
cut off your military aid did he say
that no has anyone said the president
said that what did the president of
Ukraine said no I didn't take this as a
quid pro quo
we didn't cut off aid and Joe Biden
wouldn't investigate it I'm tonight Rand
Paul
of course it was a Kentucky fest for
Bevins big thing Rand Paul was at this
rally and he kind of was pushed in the
Senate to be really strong yeah
president Trump has great courage he
faces down the fake media every day but
Congress needs to step up and have equal
courage to defend the president if
Shifty's ship will not let hunter Biden
come and if you will not bring the
whistleblower for every Republican in
Congress should take a walk and say this
is a farce he's going to walk out I mean
if you know if you don't have these
types of witnesses walk out what are
your thoughts on that yeah I really
believe the whistleblower statute has
become a dangerous tool in the wrong
hands
a whistleblower statute is designed to
keep somebody from being fired if they
report corruption it was never designed
to keep somebody anonymous it's not in
the statute itself so our like Senator
Grassley Grassley but all due respect
you can't prosecute somebody and
Pietschmann is the political death
penalty based on an anonymous source so
yes Rand is right we need the
whistleblowers name
we need who they are and they need to be
cross-examined under oath about any
vices they may have number two we need
to look at whether or not hunter Biden
corruptly engaged in lobbying did Joe
Biden s the prosecutor to be fired
because he was investigating a son and
John Solomon one of your guests coming
up has given us plenty to look at so I
hope chairman rish the Foreign
Intelligence Chairman will open up an
investigation about the role of the
State Department in all this State
Department going back to the Reagan
years Lindsay
senator Graham lenses have been it's
just always a thorn in the side of
conservatives I mean it just is because
they have a different world view I mean
they do and they're burrowed in and
they're the in for the long haul
so just what John is found is some
communications where we're going to get
into this in just a moment the bottom
line is the company that hunter Biden
was serving as a board member they went
to the State Department and said if the
prosecutor doesn't leave hunter buying a
layoff it's going to hurt us now that to
me is a bombshell of all bombshells
which
should lead to a Senate investigation of
how we should not call him and all
members of batteries this how could he
not so the the member of the board
actually met with John Kerry let's move
on though to what's happening on this
whistleblower front because the
whistleblowers attorney said we will
submit written answers senator Graham so
right now what could be wrong with
Whitten answers I mean come on
just real uh let the Hemmer if you are
charged with the crime and the person
accusing their wrongdoing
they don't have the ability to say I'll
take written questions you have a
constitutional right to confront your
accuser and this idea of saying they
will take written questions violates
every norm of due process can you
imagine if a Republican had done this to
a Democrat that way a whistleblower that
we would keep anonymous accusing a
Democratic president of wrongdoing and
they said they'll take written questions
the whole town would blow up but didn't
Trump submit written questions when he
was said yeah yeah he's the president
the United States right he's the target
of an investigation and they agreed upon
written questions when you accuse
somebody of a crime you can't do it
anonymously you can't get a parking
ticket based on an anonymous source now
a lot of people forget that Senator
Graham was an impeachment manager down
this road Pietschmann so you've been
down this road any other advice for the
Senators I mean you put on you were an
impeachment manager you can put on a
case in the Senate you go and get
present your your position the senators
don't get to ask questions right they
just have to sit and listen but you can
make you and that's written questions
yeah but not you can't interrupt the
impeachment manager but here's what I
would tell my fellow senators and every
impeachment except this one was
conducted by outside counsel I'm the one
guy that said Muller wasn't on a witch
hunt a lot of people but I took a lot of
heat I think from me yeah but here's
what I said I trust the guy to do his
job I introduced legislation saying he
couldn't be fired without cause Adam
Schiff is not looking for the truth
Jerry Nadler is not looking for the
truth what's going on in the house is a
bunch of partisan BS every Republican
senator they signed on my resolution
saying the process wasn't fair we should
continue to prosecute the people
prosecuting the president which
let every American know this is the
first time in history anybody's ever
been impeach bipartisan that if you
think Adam Schiff is out to get to truth
you shouldn't be in the United States
Senate all of us should be throwing the
BS flag on this process in the house
what is it Graham great to see you
tonight thanks for coming on we really
appreciate it